um
we just feel really grateful you know
that the film's being recognized
yeah i mean it's about community you
know it took a village to make this film
and so it's all about the community you
know film independence sundance
institute the trifecta film institute
infp all holding hands to help support
the film you know our amazing executive
producers who i forgot to thank because
spike lee mary jane stahlstein sam hart
and susan lewis you know all of them you
know holding taking our vision holding
our hands through the process
the most important thing so i was
blessed to have made the past come
together
right now but
so we never even thought twice about
bringing her into audition because you
know we looked at her as a multifaceted
person one that could do comedy but also
drama and she was the one that really
got the ball ability that we
yeah needed you know our dvd bradford
yacht was amazing he built lights you
know i spent hours and hours with him
and our gaffer and our key grip figuring
out ways to be efficient you know we
shot in 18 days uh in fort greene
brooklyn 11 of those 18 days were in one
location and you know in order to do
that we had that really
incredible not only created but
technical so we spent a lot of time in
prep figuring out how to be efficient
and trying to get out of the way so that
the artist could work
you know meet the characters
and find a good producer you know find a
good producer that's going to help build
community about around your vision
around your films
often you find like young writer
directors that figure out that they can
do it all and you can't you need support
you've got to build a team of people
that believe in your vision believe in
helping you tell your story
aside
but i mean our film is you know about
identity it's about
this universal concept
so sorry paris's bernie was you know
pretty the only other film that i
referenced and looked at because it's a
world where the filmmakers thrust you in
they don't explain to the audience and
hold your hand even though they are kind
of like explaining the world but
in the same way before i wanted to push
the audience in and trust that smart
guys forget it and we didn't want to
over explain to be able to relate to
this main character
thank you
foreign